الحرب الاوكرانيه لم تكمل عاما كاملا بعد
لكنها اثبتت انها واحده من اكثر الحروب
الحديثه تكلفه ماديا وبشريا لنتحدث
مشاهدينا عن هذه الخسائر بالارقام وفقا
للقياده العامه الاوكرانيه فان اجمالي
الخسائر البشريه للقوات الروسيه بلغت ما
يقرب من 120 الفا من الافراد العسكريين
اما المصادر الرسميه الروسيه فاعترفت
بمقتل خمسه
الافث جنديا فقط حتى ديسمبر الماضي فيما
قدم المسؤولون الامريكيون والاوروبيون
مؤخرا تقييمات للخسائر البشريه على
الجانبين تتراوح بين 180 الف الى 200 الف
قتيل وجريح روسي ومئه الف قتيل وجريح
اوكرانيا اما بالنسبه لخسائر العتاد فان
اجمالي الخسائر القتاليه للقوات الروسيه
وفقا للقياده العامه الاوكرانيه بلغت 380
دبابه مصفحه واكثر من سته الاف مركبه
قتاليه
نظام مدفعي واكثر من 400 نظام صاروخي
واكثر من 200 نظام دفاع جوي واكثر من
800 مسيره